every day I wake up knowing that the
more people I try to save more enemies I
will make and it's just a matter of time
before I face those with more power I
can overcome
I'm so sorry I'm late
I had a traffic thing did your traffic
jam have anything to do with being I
don't know shot at by machine guns yeah
yeah the house implies that was implying
that he's a park there you help or
you're gonna want to see this özgür get
you under surveillance
why is not the question of the day
there's something you're not telling me
I once told you that secrets have a cost
the truth does to my name is Richard
Parker I have discovered what Oscorp was
going to use my research for I have a
responsibility to protect the world from
what I know they're capable of what is
the future we literally can change the
world what about Peter not everyone has
a happy ending
this is bigger than you Peter
I made a choice this is my Paul
so everyone who is sitting
know how it feels to live in world
without power
merci
look out spud
you